l'année prochaine sera marquée par deux
élections majeures les présidentielles
fin avril début mai et les législatives
qui se dérouleront au mois de juin mais
pour voter il faut s'inscrire sur les
listes électorales et ça concerne ceux
qui ont déménagé on fait le point avec
mélanie poker on saura alors l'échéance
approche et c'est même plus proche qu'on
ne le pense vous avez donné les dates
des scrutins et pour les inscriptions
des sur les listes le délai d'encore
plus court la fin c'est le 31 décembre à
23h59 donc plus que trois semaines pour
s'inscrire et particularité cette année
le 31 décembre thomas samedi donc les
services municipaux ferme ta midi ce qui
fait de mi journée en moi pour
s'inscrire alors quelles sont les
démarches à suivre alors il ya plusieurs
possibilités on peut se rendre
directement à la mairie sur place on
vous fera remplir un formulaire
cerfa pour gagner du temps vous pouvez
aussi l'imprimé le remplir de chez vous
on le trouve facilement sur internet
alors on valoir aussi il ya plusieurs
documents apportés le cerfa qu'elle l'un
des documents à présenter il faut aussi
avoir une pièce d'identité un
justificatif de domicile plusieurs
documents sont acceptés les factures les
factures de gaz ou d'électricité
les factures de téléphone
il y aussi les déclarations d'impôts et
même les quittances de loyer et le
passage en mairie après qu'on attrape
des cons à tout ça ça prend moins de 5
minutes car il fallait pas agent
administratif de la ville de plaisir
nous donne la suite du calendrier alors
avant la carte d'électeur ils reçoivent
un récépissé d'inscription qui rappelle
leur état civil et qui leur indiquent
leurs bureaux de vote une fois que le
dossier bien sûr passer en commission
électorale et la carte électorale
n'arrive que courant mars 2010 est donc
on peut aussi s'inscrire sur internet
via le site service public.fr mais je
crois que toutes les communes ne sont
pas concernés en effet sur sur 50 ans
lui mine c'est le cas de maurepas les
clayes-sous-bois d'elancourt de
villepreux et de la verrière elles ne
sont pas reliés au service
gouvernemental
il faut donc se déplacer à tous les
coups avec une année électorale
présidentielle les inscriptions il faut
le savoir elle explose parce qu'à
plaisir d'habitude ce sont entre 300 et
500 nouvelles demandes d'inscriptions
pour une année dans celles comme celle
de 2017 leurs services enregistre plus
de deux mille faux l'inscription et pour
ceux qui n'auraient pas le temps de
s'inscrire ou qui auraient même oublié
il leur restera juste la procuration
merci mélanie poker